-Sir, Paul Rudd wants you
to see "Bros."
-What's up, Paul Rudd?
-You guys gonna see "Bros"?
My new movie, September 30th.
-I'm one of the Bros
so I got to watch.
-Tell all your bros
to see "Bros."
-Come on, man. Yeah. [Bleep].
Yeah.
-A lot of gay sex in it.
-Whoa.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Billy Eichner.
It's been
a while since you've been
back out doing
"Billy on the Street."
-We just released that video.
It's the first "Billy on
the Street" in three years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
If you haven't seen it,
it's all over my YouTube
and social media.
Check it out. Paul Rudd was kind
enough to come and do it.
He's done it before.
He's amazing at it.
He's fearless.
And it was really fun.
And it's -- You know, for years
I've been running around
shouting about actors and movie
stars and their movies.
This is the first time I get to
shout about my own movie.
-Yeah, there you go.
It's about time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got to shoot the film in
New York, and obviously having
done "Billy on the Street"
with you as well,
that's a lot of running
through the streets of New York.
It is not a controlled set.
It's very catch as catch can.
-You've done it, yeah.
-Was it nice to, one, shoot in
a city you're comfortable with
and, two, sort of on controlled
sets where you --
-Yes, I love "Billy on the
Street," but it's nice to also
work with actors who've had,
like, scripted lines to say.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But yeah, I mean,
it was written --
not to get too sentimental about
it, but, you know, I grew up
loving those romantic comedies,
you know, that I mentioned like
"When Harry Met Sally"
and all of those movies.
And it always, you know,
features like, you know,
a couple walking around Central
Park and making witty banter.
And me and Luke were doing that
and shooting here
on the Upper West Side,
and I did take a moment to think
to myself, you know, "Wow, this
is amazing, I'm doing one of
those movies that I love,
but it's about someone like me."
It's about a gay male couple
at the center of it.
And it's real and it's honest.
And it's funny I hope, and that,
I'm very grateful for that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amazing.
Another thing I'm assuming --
-And let me just say
one more thing.
-Please.
-Because people -- you know,
people don't respect
romantic comedies, right?
And those are the movies
that I love, you know?
And they're not taken seriously.
But the truth is,
you know, I'm a gay man.
"Brokeback Mountain"
is a great movie.
I've seen it once.
"Pretty Woman"
I've seen 50 times.
[ Laughter ]
So let's support
romantic comedies because we
secretly all love them.
-Well, you know what
I will tell you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every time I'm on a plane
and I choose the movie that
everybody is --
the important movie everybody
has told me I had to see.
If someone in a row ahead is
watching a romantic comedy,
I realize I just watch
that without sound.
-Yes. Right, yeah, yeah.
-Because your eyes are like,
"I remember that."
-Yeah, exactly.
You're watching
"My Best Friend's Wedding"
through like a small little --
like between seats.
-And I'm like,
"Why am I fighting it?
Why am I not just getting it
on my screen?"
This is pretty cool.
Mariah Carey hosted one of your
first screenings of the film.
-Yes, she did. Not only that.
On her own volition she had
a "Bros" dress made
with the logo of "Bros."
Mariah has a song in the movie.
-Which, again, amazing.
-Yeah, it's incredible.
I had to get in touch with her
to get permission to use it.
It's in the scene where
my love interest and I meet.
And Mariah comes up a few times
during the movie
because of that.
And then she said "no"
and we sent her the movie
and she loved it and she hosted
a screening and made this dress.
I mean, I literally, no joke, in
like -- what was it, 1992, 1993,
had my first kiss with a girl,
which shows you
how long ago it was.
[ Laughter ]
But I had my first kiss
with a girl listening to
a Mariah Carey song.
-Well, there you go.
Full circle.
Some pretty fun cameos at
the end of the film.
-There sure are, Seth.
Who you talking about?
-Well, I don't know.
-Yeah.
-It's just cool.
It's just like a cool thing
to stick around till the end.
-Yeah, exactly.
Don't want to give anything
away.
-Yeah, just might be kind of
cool to watch.
-Yeah, exactly, yes.
Some of your favorite
"Late Night" stars from NBC
might be featured at
the end of the movie.
-Yeah, maybe.
Might, I don't know.
-Who knows?
-Just go.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-So, like all rom-coms, there
are sex scenes in this film.
And I am wondering if that
inspired you to get in, what --
let's be honest --
you're in fantastic shape.
-Well, thank you for that.
-Yes.
-I did my best, but it's because
I had to be on screen.
You saw Luke Macfarlane.
-Yeah.
-He's like the best-looking
person anyone has ever seen.
-He also looks like a person
who has never been in bad shape.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-He's always looked like
Superman.
He's like gay Superman,
you know.
I mean, Superman himself was
pretty gay.
[ Laughter ]
He was definitely bi.
-Yeah.
-He was definitely bi.
But no, you know,
it's interesting
'cause I wrote it with Nick.
You know, I just kept thinking,
yeah, we're two guys
but Judd Apatow movies have a
history of hilarious sex scenes
and physical comedy
and, you know, "Trainwreck" --
and when Kristen Wiig
and Jon Hamm
are together at the beginning of
"Bridesmaids."
And I thought, "Well, why can't
we do that, too?
Just because we're two guys.
We're just doing it for laughs
to be funny."
But you never think
while writing it,
"Oh, I'm going to have to do
that."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I swear you just think,
"What's the funniest thing
that could happen
for these characters?
Okay, yeah, they're naked
and they're wrestling
and they're having sex
and blah, blah, blah."
And then I thought,
"Oh, God, that's me."
[ Laughter ]
Now I go and I sit
and I watch it
on a movie screen
with other people.
Last night we had a premiere in
New York.
My half-brother had to sit
through that.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you put the work in
and it paid off.
-Thank you.
-First of all, it's always
a delight to have you here.
-I love you.
-But especially for this.
It is such a wonderful film.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
Everybody go see "Bros."
-Go see "Bros"!
-It's in theaters
September 30th.
We'll be right back
with Beth Ditto.